[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
Siebers guten Abend ihnen allen an einem
Tag an dem man mit Krawatte gefährlich
lebt an dem ztausende den Beginn des
Straßenkarnevals gefeiert haben und sich
auch von strömendem Regen nicht davon
abhalten ließen an einem Tag der Sorgen
vergessen lässt und dennoch nicht
wegkommt von der Welt in der wir leben
wir beginnen deshalb heute mit der
erstaunlichen Geschichte einer Frau die
ihre Heimat verlassen musste nach
Deutschland floh und jetzt in Düsseldorf
an den Wagen für den rosenmtagszug
mitarbeitet unter anderem an einem
Mottowagen der den Mann zeigt vor dem
sie floh Norman odental erzählt ihre
Geschichte
es ist die Freiheit mit den Händen zu
formen den Gedanken zu spielen wo auch
immer sie hinführen Kunst eben Marina
Bildhauerin kann wieder sie selbst sein
in ihrer neuen Heimat Düsseldorf in
ihrer alten Heimat Moskau geht das
nicht Freiheit gibt es keines dieses
Wort in Russland schade aber so als
Kunstler wenn du kann verstecken deine
Meinung ja zwischen
zwischen Buchstabe zwischen fararbe du
kannst arbeiten aber du bist immer du
hast immer
Angst wenn jemand sagt das ist verbotene
Sache marina hat Verbotenes getan gegen
das Regime demonstriert gegen Putin
siebenm habe man sie festgenommen grün
und blau geprügelt als der Angriff auf
die Ukraine begann wurde es für Marina
endgültig zu
gefährlich ich habe keine andere spreche
ein bisschen viel und wenn ich bleibe da
ich denke mein Leben nicht weit von
navalni kan gefä ja das ist nächste
Schritt hier in Freiheit mit neue Leben
neue Sprache neue Aufgabe oder gefängers
in
Russland sie haben alles hinter sich
gelassen
alles
alles 2000 km luftlin von enternt eine
andere Welt Karneval in Düsseldorf am
Rhein politisch satirisch bissig frei
putin ist hier seit Jahren sehr beliebt
als Zielscheibe undenkbar dass so etwas
auf moskauerstraßen rollt für Marina war
das hier eine Befreiung wenn ich habe
gesehen knaval erste Mal letztes
Jahr ich verstehe dass das ist
meine
ichit geh zu raten ihr Freunde und
arbeitet sie jetzt in der Werkstatt
einer wahren Legende jacqu ist der
Wagenbauer im politischen Karneval ein
Glücksfall für
Marina
undgekehrtemandhaftig erzählt wie halt
die künstlerische Freiheit in Russland
eigentlich verunmöglicht wird im Moment
da ist es natürlich noch mal für uns
eine
Motivation ja besonderen Augenmerk auf
Russland zu legen gerade auch in diesem
Jahr mehr verrät der Meister nicht mit
närischer Strenge werden die politischen
motivagen
B Montag mor hinter verschlossenen Türen
wird ein putinwagen geben am
rosenmag das ist ein geheim
ja aber ja es gibt Putin dieses Jahr
auch und sie haben daran mitgearbeitet
ja ich
habearbeitet Marina balisch gegen
Vladimir Putin der Kampf tobt weiter
doch diese Runde geht gefühlt zumindest
an
Marina
der ukrainekrieg also auch Thema bei den
Narren in einer verdammt ernsten Welt
dazu heute eine Entwicklung die sich
abgezeichnet hatte die nichtsdestotrotz
aufhorchen lässt und die wir jetzt
analysieren werden der ukrainische
Präsident stellt die militärische
Führung seines Landes neu auf der
General der als Oberbefehlshaber der
Streitkräfte die Ukraine durch fast zwe
Jahre Krieg geführt hatte muss gehen das
ist er Valeri salusni sehr beliebt bei
den Menschen in der Ukraine ein
Kriegsheld für viele aber Präsident
zelenski sagt heute wir brauchen eine
realistische Strategie für
2024 bringen wir unsere Korrespondentin
mit dazu Katrin Eigendorf in Kiev guten
Abend Katrin was sind denn die Gründe
für diese Ablösung hatte die Ukraine
keine realistische Strategie
bislang ja Christian das ist einerseits
eine Frage des persönlichen
Verhältnisses und das steht glaube ich
im Vordergrund rund das Zerwürfnis
zwischen salusini und selenski dauert
schon eine ganze Weile der General wurde
dem Präsidenten einfach zu selbstbewusst
er hat mit der Presse gesprochen ohne
das mit ihm ab
abzusprechen das kommt auch in einem
Moment wo man sagen muss dass die
Ukraine auch militärisch keine wirklich
guten Rezepte mehr hat salusni hat
gegenüber dem britischen conomist auch
ganz offen davon gesprochen dass wir
mittlerweile eine patzsituation haben
das heißt er hat die Strategie
eigentlich in Frage gestellt dass
die Ukraine hier das gesamte besetzte
von Russland besetzte Territorium
zurückerobert und das ist eigentlich das
Problem in der Strategie was dazu
geführt hat dass er jetzt entlassen
wurde also die Ukraine braucht dringend
eine neue Strategie auch in diesem Krieg
die Offensive gegen Russland kann man
eigentlich als gescheitert bezeichnen ja
dann gucken wir uns doch den neuen
Armeechef an Alexander sirski katr du
hast gerade erst getroffen bringt er
denn diese neue Strategie
mit ja ich habe ihn gerade äh getroffen
wir haben die Gelegenheit gehabt in
harkiv mit ihm ein längeres Interview zu
führen er steht für militärische Erfolge
der Ukraine zu Beginn des Krieges er hat
dafür gesorgt dass die Russen es nicht
geschafft haben Kiev die Hauptstadt
einzunehmen er hat auch weite Gebiete
zurück erobert er steht für eine relativ
harte Führung und ist auch bereit seine
Soldaten erbittert um jeden Kilometer
Land kämpfen zu lassen dafür steht er
als Stratege er kennt beide Seiten das
zeichnet ihn aus also er kennt auch die
russische Seite hat in Moskau studiert
er kennt auch die westliche Seite gut in
seiner Ausbildung und was er uns im
Interview gesagt hat er weiß welche
Rolle moderne Technologie in diesem
Krieg spielen wird da hat er klare
Konzepte vorgelegt wie z.B Drohnen zum
Erfolg führen könnten
das könnte durchaus eine Art ja neue
Strategie hier verheißen
nichtsdestotrotz ist das natürlich ein
enormer Schaden den die Ukraine hier
jetzt nach außen auch ja hat denn es ist
nicht gut ein Land das vorher als geeint
galt dass es jetzt so dar steht dass es
hier ein so schweres Zerwürfnis im
Prinzip gegeben hat interessante Analyse
herzlichen Dank Katrin Eigendorf live
aus Kiev heute Abend und wir bleiben
noch einen Moment beim Thema und gucken
nach Russland die freie gleiche geheime
Wahl in einer Demokratie Basis für alles
weitere der Moment in dem sich der Wille
des Volkes zeigt in Russland ist Mitte
März Präsidentenwahl die heißt zwar so
aber wer sie gewinnen wird ist bereits
jetzt klar auch weil es keine echte
Auswahl gibt ein Kandidat der
heraussticht weil er als einziger
Bewerber offen den Krieg gegen die
Ukraine ablehnt ist heute selbst
abgelehnt worden die Wahlkommission hat
ihn nicht zugelassen n Niebergall mit
mehr Baris nadestin wollte den
mächtigsten Mann Russlands herausfordern
Vladimir Putin am Morgen entscheidet
sich ob er antreten darf bei der
Präsidentschaftswahl im März das Urteil
der Wahlkommission die Unterschriften
seien gefälscht die nestin brauchte um
anzutreten der oppositionelle wird nicht
zugelassen sie können mich problemlos
aus der Wahl entfernen aber wohin mit
den Millionen Menschen ein Wandel wollen
und mit dem Kurs der im Land verfolgt
wird nicht einverstanden
sind auf den Straßen Moskaus wollen
viele lieber nicht über Politik reden
eine Wahl haben sie sowieso nicht es ist
egal putin wird viele Stimmen bekommen
es spielt keine Rolle ob nestin zur Wahl
zugelassen
wird ich habe Zweifel dass die
Wahlkommission richtig gezählt hat
selbst wenn n die Wahl nicht gewinnen
würde ärgert mich dass er nicht
teilnehmen
darf s wohl diese Bilder die das
putinreime verhindern wollte in den
vergangenen Wochen unterschrieben
plötzlich zetausende in ganz Russland
für nandestin den einzigen Kandidaten
der offen gegen den Krieg
ist so wie hier in Podolsk 40 km vor
Moskau in einem Land in dem Protest kaum
mehr möglich ist ein mächtiges
Zeichen das ist die einzige Möglichkeit
irgendwie unsere antikriegs und unsere
antiutin Haltung zu bekunden
es ist wichtig Einheit zu zeigen die
jungen Menschen haben sich vereint für
sie hat sich eine Hoffnung
eröffnet er war der einzige
Hoffnungsträger den die kriegsmüden die
kriegskritiker hatten auch wenn er nie
besonders laut oder besonders provokant
war nie et den strengenensurgeseten in
russlanderspr sind laut nestins Team
mehr als die nötigen 100000 Stimmen
zusammengekommen ein Teil davon sei
ungültig heißt es
nun laut allen Umfragen lag ich auf dem
zweiten Platz bereits im zweistelligen
Bereich und sie erzählen mir von elf
Unterschriften angeblich toter oder
falschen
Passdaten nadestin kündigt an vor
Gericht zu ziehen auch wenn er kaum eine
Chance haben dürfte auf dem Wahlzettel
im März wird niemand stehen der Putin
ernsthaft
herausfordert und dann wählt heute ein
Land das reich ist an traumhaften
Panoramen und warmherziger
Gastfreundschaft Pakistan ist das
fünftgrößte Land der Erde nach
Einwohnerzahl 240 Millionen Menschen
rund 130 Millionen
Wahlberechtigte das ist die eine Seite
die andere bittere Armut marode
Wirtschaft galoppierende Inflation die
Wahl in dem Atomstaat wird begleitet von
Bombenanschlägen Gewalt und
Einschüchterungen
Menschenrechtsorganisationen prangern an
dass Pakistans Justiz die Opposition
weitgehend demontiert hat Johannes Hano
ist in
Pakistan als wir in der 25 Millionen
Einwohner Metropole Karachi landen wird
uns auf dem Weg in die Stadt schlagartig
klar vor welchen enormen
Herausforderungen jede künftige
Regierung hier in Pakistan stehen wird
nur eine Stunde hatte es vor unserer
Ankunft und große Teile der Stadt stehen
praktisch unter Wasser auch am nächsten
Morgen ist das Wasser noch nicht überall
abgelaufen in den engen Gassen von Yari
einem Stadtteil karacis wollen wir
wissen was sich die Menschen von einer
neuen Regierung
erwarten was wir brauchen ist
Elektrizität Wasser und Benzin mehr
brauchen wir nicht wir helfen uns schon
selber aber das brauchen
wir die macht Pakistan und die Mehrheit
ihrer 250 Millionen Menschen steht vor
dem wirtschaftlichen Kollaps die
Inflation um die 30% viele Menschen
haben kein Geld mehr um sich Essen zu
kaufen viele lokale Firmen wie hier im
Industriegebiet von Karachi kämpfen ums
wirtschaftliche Überleben der
Kühlerhersteller Pakistan Engineering
produziert Kühler für Traktoren und LKW
für den einheimischen Markt Rohstoffe
wie Kupfer müssen sie importieren und
teuer mit Dollar bezahlen aber woher
nehmen wenn es praktisch keine Export
Industrie gibt die Dollar ins Land
bringt die wirtschaftlichen Probleme in
Pakistan sind derzeit sehr groß die
Rohstoffpreise steigen wir haben fast
keine Dollar und dann ist der
Wechselkurs zum Dollar auch nicht stabil
in einer solchen Situation können wir
unsere Geschäfte nicht
planen und als wäre das Leben nicht
schon schwer genug wird Pakistan seit
Jahren von einer Welle der gewalteim
gesucht viele Pakistani sind überzeugt
dass nur ein Mann sie aus der Misere
führen kann wir sind im Parteibüro im
Wahlkreis des ehemaligen pakistanischen
Premierministers Imran Khan in Islamabad
der aber sitzt im
Gefängnis wir konkurrieren in diesem
Wahlkampf nicht mit unseren politischen
Gegnern wir konkurrieren mit den
Institutionen und der Polizei im ran KH
der religiöse Populist der die Wahl nach
allen Umfragen wohl mit großem
vorschwung gewonnen hätte wurde kurz vor
den Wahlen unter anderem wegen
Korruption zu mehr als 30 Jahren
Gefängnis verurteilt die Kandidaten
seiner Partei PTI dürfen nur als
unabhängige Kandidaten
antreten es ist sehr schlecht was mit
der PTI passiert es wurde gemacht um
deren Wähler zu entmutigen aber die
Wähler kennen mittlerweile die Tricks
des politischen Establishments und des
Militärs noch steht nicht fest wer die
Wahlen gewonnen hat sicher ist nur dass
der Atommacht Pakistan unruhige Zeiten
bevorstehen ja noch mal nachgefragt in
Pakistan Johannes guten Abend egal wer
gewinnt ist denn irgendwie absehbar wie
ein Wahlsieger diese immensen
Herausforderungen die du da gerade
beschrieben hast meistern
kann also wir haben mit vielen Analysten
von allen politischen Richtungen
gesprochen und alle haben uns eigentlich
eines gesagt ohne drastische politische
Reform gibt es keine Zukunft für
Pakistan Pakistan braucht ein neues
politisches System bisher hat noch kein
Premierminister seit staatsgrüung ist
geschafft eine volle Amtszeit zu
überstehen und seine Politik nachhaltig
und konsistent überhaupt durchzuführen
und das liegt daran dass das Militär im
Hintergrund die feden zieht das Militär
ist einer der größten Arbeitgeber das
Militär besitzt selber Fabriken und hat
kein Interesse an einer erfolgreichen
zivilen Regierung die möglicherweise die
vormachtschellung des Militärs in Frage
stellen könnte was passieren muss ist
und da sind sich auch alle einig dass
die Parteien zusammenarbeiten um eine
starke Zivilgesellschaft gegen das
Militär aufzubauen das man allerdings
auch braucht sagt man uns immer wieder
weil man viele Gegner und Feinde in der
Region hat Afghanistan Iran und so
weiter wenn jetzt Pakistan
wirtschaftlich und politisch weiter
taumeln sollte was ja Beiner anzunehmen
ist leider welche Folgen hat denn das
für die Region und die
Welt also US-Präsident Biden hat ich
glaube vor 2wei Jahren gesagt Pakistan
sei die gefährlichste Nation der Welt
und das hängt damit zusammen dass
Pakistan 170 Atomsprengköpfe besitzt und
wenn das Land im Chaos versinkt wonach
es aussieht im Moment dann besteht die
große Sorge dass Terrororganisation wie
der islamische stad der heute erst
wieder hier Anschläge verübt hat oder
al-Qaida aber auch der Iran sich in den
Besitz der Atomwaffen Versuch zu bringen
und das hätte natürlich große Folgen für
den Rest der Welt was wir hier auch
immer wieder gehört haben ist die
pakistanische Bevölkerung wächst mit
2,5% die hatten Durchschnittsalter
glaube ich von 26 Jahren wenn die jungen
Leute keine Zukunft haben werden die
sich als soldiers for higher also als
Söldner verdingen möglicherweise und die
ganze Region unsicher machen morgen
Vormittag soll es erste Ergebnisse geben
wir werden weiter berichten du wirst
weiterberichten Johannes für den Moment
herzlichen Dank Johannes hanno war das
live aus
Islamabad
und weiter hier jetzt mit einem ersten
Nachrichtenüberblick und dir Hanna
Bundeskanzler Scholz ist zu einem Besuch
in Washington aufgebrochen bei den
Gesprächen mit US-Präsident beiden wird
der Fokus morgen auch auf den
Militärhilfen für die Ukraine liegen der
US-Senat hatte gestern ein hilspaket
blockiert nun soll noch einmal über
einen geänderten Entwurf abgestimmt
werden vor seiner Abreise rief Scholz
die USA und auch die anderen
europäischen Verbündeten zu weiterer
Unterstützung für die Ukraine auf die
bisher zugesagten Hilfen seien nicht
genug so scholzwörtlich die unterstüung
bei Angriffen des israelischen Militärs
auf rafach im Süden des Gazastreifens
sind in der Nacht nach palästinensischen
Angaben mindestens 13 Menschen getötet
worden der israelische Ministerpräsident
Netanyahu hatte gestern eine Ausweitung
des Militäreinsatzes in dem Gebiet
angekündigt der Grenzstadt rafach leben
laut UN mittlerweile mehr als eine
Million Menschen viele von ihnen S sind
vor den Kämpfen aus dem Norden
geflüchtet im Tarifstreit um eine
bessere Bezahlung von Beschäftigten in
Arztpraxen gibt es eine Einigung das hat
der Verband medizinischer Fachberufe
mitgeteilt zu den genauen Details gibt
es bisher keine Angaben diese sollen
erst Ende nächster Woche bekannt gegeben
werden mit einem bundesweiten eintägigen
Warnstreik hatten die medizinischen
Fachangestellten heute ihren Forderungen
Nachdruck verliehen es geht um höhere
Gehälter für zu 330 000
Beschäftigte Bundeswirtschaftsminister
habbeck ist nach Algerien gereist um die
Energiepartnerschaft mit dem
nordafrikanischen Land zu festigen
konkret geht es um den Import von grünem
Wasserstoff habck unterschrieb dazu eine
Absichtserklärung der Wasserstoff wird
in Algerien mit Hilfe von Solarenergie
hergestellt das Land plant seine
Kapazitäten deutlich auszubauen um
künftig bis zu 10% des europäischen
Bedarfs decken zu können über eine
Pipeline soll der grüne Wasserstoff dann
über Italien und Österreich auch nach
Deutschland transportiert
werden die Erderwärmung nimmt zu so lag
sie erstmals 12 Monate infolge im
Durchschnitt über 1,5° gemessen zur
vorindustriellen Zeit das hat der EU
klimawandeldienst Kopernikus mitgeteilt
zudem hat die Erde den wärmsten je
gemessenen Januar erlebt
durchschnittlich war er 1 66° wärmer als
die januarmonate zwischen 1850 und
1900 eine schnelle Verringerung des
Treibhausgasausstoßes sei der einzige
Weg um den Anstieg der Temperaturen zu
stoppen mnten die
Wissenschaftler es ist eine lange Reise
zu der die Fregatte Hessen heute
aufgebrochen ist und eine Reise ins
Ungewisse die Hessen ist der Beitrag der
deutschen Marine der Beitrag
Deutschlands zu einer neuen
Militäroperation mit der die Staaten der
Europäischen Union die Handelsschiffahrt
auf einer der weltweit wichtigsten
Routen sichern wollen die Hessen macht
sich also vom Stützpunkt in wilhelmsafen
auf via Mittelmeer ins Rote Meer dort wo
hui Milizen aus dem Jemen seit Oktober
westliche Handelsschiffe beschießen die
Hessen dürfte schon bald gewaltigen
Herausforderungen gegenüber stehen die
Marine spricht vom gefährlichsten
Einsatz seit Jahrzehnten Ines
strans nun geht alles ganz schnell nach
langwierigen Verhandlungen in Berlin und
Brüssel legt die Fregatte Hessen ab in
Richtung rotes Meer gibt in zwei Wochen
der Bundestag grünes Licht für die
Mission aspides dann will sie schon im
Einsatzgebiet sein für die Angehörigen
ein emotionaler Moment
beklommen sehr
beklommen weil in paar Wochen wird unser
Sohn Vater und dann ist es natürlich
schwierig bei so ein langen
Einsatz 50 Männer und Frauen auf dem Weg
in einen scharfen Einsatz gemeinsam mit
zwei anderen europäischen Kriegsschiffen
sollen sie Handelsschiffe vor den
Attacken der hudi Schützen das ist der
ernsthafteste Einsatz einer deutschen
Marineeinheit seit vielen Jahrzehnten
schwer bewaffnet ist sie die
jemenitische terrormiliz der hudi immer
wieder Angriffe aus der Luft auf
Frachter im Roten Meer diese Geschosse
sollen die Kriegsschiffe künftig
abfahren wir rechnen mit dem gesamten
Spektrum von direkten und indirekten
Angriffen das reicht von ballistischen
Flugkörpern großer Reichweite bis hin zu
Drohnen und auch auch kleinstdrohnen
aber auch ferngestuerte
Überwassereinheiten im kamikaz Betrieb
die Fregatte Hessen ist für diesen
Einsatz gut gerüstet ihre Radarsysteme
haben eine Reichweite von 400 km ihre
abwehrwaffen können bis zu 160 km weit
fliegen die Räder hoffen nun auf freie
Seewege dass wir wieder gefahrlos durch
das Rote Meer und damit auch durch den
Sueskanal fahren können denn es geht ein
Großteil etwa der deutschen Versorgung
der Bevölkerung mit Energie und Gütern
durch diese seestrecke die Amerikaner
und die Britten sind schon länger vor
Ort sie beschießen auch hudi Stellung an
Land das soll die defensiv ausgerichtete
eu- missission explizit nicht machen die
konfliktursache wird so nicht beseitigt
um die H Milizen wirklich bekämp zu
können oder schlagen eindrängen wie auch
immer zu können muss man an Land gehen
nur mit dem Abwehren von Drohnen oder
Flugkörpern auf See wird man das
grundsätzliche Problem nicht lösen
können so könnte es sein dass die
Handelsschiffe noch länger mit Angriffen
der hudi rechnen müssen zumindest
solange der Iran sie unterstützt der
Iran ist in den vergangenen Monaten in
die Enge gedrängt worden er hat Position
verloren politisch wie militärisch im
nahen mitleren Osten fühlt sich bedroht
und es gibt kein Indiz dafür dass die
hui Rebellen oder dahinter stehend der
Iran einknicken würden im Gegenteil sie
drohen mit
Eskalation gut vorbereitet sei die
Mannschaft der Hessen heißt es doch es
bleibt eine riskante Mission die Marine
spricht von einer neuen Dimension von
Einsatz ja damit zurück nach Deutschland
und zu dir Hanna die Kaufpreise für
Wohnungen und Häuser sind einer Studie
zufolge im vergangenen Jahr so stark
gesunken wie seit mindestens 60 Jahren
nicht mehr das Keler Institut für
Weltwirtschaft spricht von einem
historisch einmaligen Preisverfall
Valerie Haller was sind die Gründe dafür
und was bedeutet das genau für all
diejenigen die jetzt kaufen wollen ja
also die Baukosten sind massiv gestiegen
die Inflation war lange hoch und vor
allem die gestiegenen Zinsen haben die
Nachfrage nach Immobilien ausgebremst
und das hat am Markt zu einem
Preisverfall geführt der seinesgleichen
sucht noch nie viel die Preise von
Immobilien in Deutschland so stark so
schnell Eigentumswohnungen waren im
Vergleich zum Vorjahr um
8,9% günstiger ein Familienhäuser
verloren
11,3% und bei mehr Familienhäusern
fielen die Preise sogar um
20,1%. aber den Preissturz ist eine
ebenfalls historische Rally
vorausgegangen über 10 Jahre lang sind
die Preise von Immobilien exorbitant
gestiegen das Institut für
Weltwirtschaft hält die Korrektur daher
nicht für besonders besorgniserregend
immerhin erwarten Experten fürs laufende
Jahr dass sich der Markt stabilisieren
könnte gibt es denn noch irgendwelche
guten Nachrichten für die vielen Mieter
in Deutschland eher nicht schon allein
deswegen weil viele Wohnungen gebraucht
werden und nicht genug Wohnraum zur
Verfügung steht laut Zahlen des
Immobilienportals Immowelt bewegen sich
die mieten bundesweit im Schnitt wieder
aufwärts nur vereinzelt sinken sie in
besonders teuren Metropolen wie München
Düsseldorf oder Frankfurt liegen die
Mieten etwas niedriger als im Vorjahr
ähnliches gilt für mittelgroße Städte
die Begründung ist vermutlich ganz
einfach die Mieten sind teils so hoch
mehr ist für viele schlicht nicht mehr
bezahlbar vielen Dank Valerie nach
Frankfurt und es gibt eine
Unwetterwarnung des Deutschen
Wetterdienstes in Teilen von
Baden-Württemberg nordrehein-westfalen
Hessen und reinernpfals kann es
weiterhin zu ergiebigem Dauerregen
kommen im Südwesten Islands ist es zum
dritten Mal innerhalb von zwei Monaten
zu einem spektakulären vulkanusbruch
gekommen aus einer etwa 3 km langen
Erdspalte schossen glutrote Lavafontänen
in die Höhe nah der blauen Lagune einer
der Touristenattraktionen des Landes
schob sich ein Lavastrom über eine
Straße weil durch den Ausbruch auch eine
Warmwasserleitung durchtrennt wurde
riefen die Behörden die notstandstufe
für die betroffene Region
eine Kollegin hier sagte heute ich
kannte den Mann nicht aber ich bin froh
dass ich die Nachrufe auf ihn gelesen
habe der Historiker Politologe Publizist
Alfred Grosser ist gestorben im Alter
von 99 Jahren und auch wem der Name
erstmal nicht so viel sagt ahnt heute
anhand der vielen Erinnerungen was
grosser geleistet hat er hat
Generationen von französischen Studenten
Deutschland nah gebracht und umgekehrt
Frankreich er hat erklärt und vermittelt
und verstehen gelehrt zwischen zwei
Völkern die sich als erbitterte Feinde
gegenüber standen in den Schützengräben
ausgerechnet grosser und gerade grosser
dessen Familie selbst unter den Nazis
gelitten hatte wurde zum geduldigen
Brückenbauer hier ist unser Nachruf von
Christiane
Hoffmann sich selbst mit den Augen des
anderen sehen Offenheit Empathie zeigen
Verbindungen schaffen bis zuletzt
schrieb Alfred Crosser an gegen Hetze
Hass und Populismus unsere Zeit mit 92
veröffentlichte er sein letztes Buch l
menensch ein Vermächtnis wir überall
gemordet und so weiter und ich glaube
doch dass meine und andere Leute Aufgabe
immer noch ist Menschen mehr zu Menschen
machen croser wird 1925 in Frankfurt am
Main geboren sein Vater Direktor der
Frankfurter kinderklin
verliert nach der machgreifung der Nazis
1933 seine Stelle die jüdische Familie
emigriert nach Frankreich cruser wird
Franzose überlebt so den
Krieg die Erfahrung von Verfolgung
Vertreibung Hass prägen ihn doch er
wendet sich nicht ab von Deutschland
sondern will vermitteln Brücken bauen er
empfinde Mitverantwortung für
Deutschland fast vier Jahrzehnte lehrt
der Publizist und Politologe an der
Elite
in zahlreichen Büchern hilft er den
deutschen die Franzosen zu verstehen und
umgekehrt gilt als einer der
intellektuellen Wegbereiter des elyise
Vertrages des deutsch-französischen
Freundschaftsvertrags von 1963 es gibt
eine Aufklärungsarbeit in Frankreich
über Deutschland in Deutschland über
Frankreich in Deutschland sage ich Gutes
über Frankreich und bös über Deutschland
in Frankreich s Bö über Frankreich und
Gutes über Deutschland das ist die
ständige Pädagogik
groser war ein ironischer freiheitlicher
Geist durch Provokationen wollte er
andere zum freien denken anstacheln für
Kritik sorgt der 2010 bei der
Gedenkfeier zur reichsbrogromnacht in
der Frankfurter Paulskirche Deutschlands
Verhältnis zu Israel sei zu unkritisch
sagt er da und fordert mit Blick auf die
Palästinenser die Anerkennung des
Leidens der anderen jedes Mal wenn wir
etwas verletzen von unseren werden die
wir behaupten zu respektieren werden wir
unglaubwürdig den anderen Kontinenten
gegenüber wenn wir für unsere Werte
predigen Bundespräsident Steinmeier und
Kanzler Scholz würdigen ihn heute als
Versöhner und scharfsinnigen Beobachter
ein inspirierender Mensch ein Denker ein
Europäer und offenbar einer mit Schalk
croser schrieb er fürchte den Tod nicht
doch er wolle kurz auferstehen um die
Nachrufe lesen zu
können und auch sein Lebensmotto darf
die Welt gerne in Erinnerung behalten
zufrieden sein ohne sich zufrieden zu
geben so viel Freude wie möglich zu
empfangen und zu geben damit entlassen
wir Sie in diese Nacht und gegen 0:15
Uhr meldet sich dann hier nasin göckte
mir mit unserem heute journal Update von
uns allen auch den Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hinter den Kameras einen
angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir schauen auf
den Rekordmonat Januar zurück es ist der
wärmste Januar weltweit betrachtet und
wir sehen vor allem auch hier über dem
Ozean ist es sehr warm gewesen das ist
schon seit vergangenem März Rekordwerte
hier und das ist auch die Ursache warum
es so viel regnet wir sehen es hier auf
unserem vorschaufilm ziemlich viel Regen
kommt hier vom Nordatlantik von der
Biskaya zu uns und verdrängt tatsächlich
die Kaltluft nach Nordosten und mit
dieser Feuchtigkeit gibt's eben auch
viel Regen 10 bis 30 ler sind noch mal
drin bis morgen Abend ja und in der
Nacht gibt's diesen vielen Regen vor
allem hier von Südwesten her kommt der
nach Nordosten gezogen und hier gibt es
tatsächlich noch mal Schnee weil es hier
viel kälter ist als im Südwesten mit
Glätte müssten sie rechnen und hier
sehen sehen Sie die Temperaturen -2° im
Nordosten und ein Bereich hier mit 0°
und da kann es eben gefährlich glatt
werden ganz anders im Südwesten bei 10°
diese warme Luft die trängt langsam nach
Nordosten morgen dann weiterer Regen
erst einmal im Südwesten auch noch
kräftig das lässt allmählich nach im
Norden ist der Regen durchaus noch
kräftig und der Schnee der wird
allmählich abgedrängt im Südosten da
lockert es auf Temperaturen bei 2° im
Norden man sieht hier wenn diese Kälte
sich durchsetzen würde wä es winterlich
aber die Wärme kommt von Südwesten 17
teils 15° und die nächsten Tage nun es
geht wechselhaft weiter am Samstag mit
18° und föneunterstützung an den Alpen
einen schönen Abend